blöde sache keiner hat mehr bock auf
corona vom gefühl her sind wir
eigentlich durch mit der alten solche
und trotzdem kommt das virus zurück sagt
quasi mit dem großen baden howard
carpendales hello again schade
möglichkeit in ganz europa ziehen die
infektionszahlen wieder deutlich an
auch in deutschland aber was macht man
jetzt mit der information
uns erreichen ja gerade wirklich sehr
verwirrende und widersprüchliche signale
beispiel bei diesem folgenden n tv
beitrag aus dem chor ohne hotspot
münchen
da passen wenn sie darauf achten bild
und ton irgendwie nicht gut zusammen in
münchen berief einen krisenstab über die
hohen infektionszahlen hier gab es in
den letzten sieben tagen 55
neuerkrankungen auf einen der 1000
einwohner
heiko will ein chor wird 16 tage
wirtshaus wiesen und zu aktiver sicher
die sehnsucht nach normalität ist der
normal nur einerseits fußball wieder vor
zuschauern weihnachtsmärkte in jedem
fall aber wir müssen alle wahnsinnig
vorsichtig sein
das kriegt mein gehirn nicht zusammen
widersprüchliche signale und überall
neue corona hotspots vor allem wegen
privater partys wegen partys bei einer
hochzeit in hamm feiern hunderte
menschen dass zwei leute eine neue
steuerklasse kriegen und sämtliche
hammer schüler dürfen deswegen wieder
maske tragen wenn wir sie kann man
eigentlich sein
klar manche argumente leuchten auch ein
guck mal das wetter es ist so schön wir
kriegen vitamin d3 sucht ohne ende
warum man keine impfung eben aber nicht
zu lange in der sonne stehen sonst wird
man impfgegner keine frage dauer
alarmismus macht wenig sinn
genau wie immer nur auf infektionszahlen
starren die sterblichkeitsrate ist im
moment niedriger als im frühjahr
unter anderem weil die kliniken
therapeutisch viel dazugelernt haben
gott sei dank
das ist aber kein grund bei abstand und
hygiene nachzulassen
man könnte auch sagen die maske bleibt
ein modisches muscat sagt auch dieser
bayerische fashion guru das ist dem ein
oder anderen die freude etwas reduzieren
lässt wenn eine maske darauf sitzt muss
das glaube ich sofort masken aufsetzen
ist kein unmittelbarer lustgewinn nein
also maske bringt kein lustgewinn
das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen ja
das kommt selbstverständlich immer auf
die maske tragen hier auch baresel ach
da fällt mir ein kleiner tipp liebe csu
überlegt vielleicht noch mal auf eure
partei slogan noch so richtig zum corona
herbst passt hier csu näher am menschen
eben nicht ähnlich krone bleibt
gefährlich selbst patienten mit milden
verlauf leiden manchmal an schlimmen
spätfolgen wie herzmuskelentzündung und
ein arzt aus brilon ein gewisser sekunde
dr friedrich merz hat gerade eine
bislang völlig unbekannte corona
nebenwirkung entdeckt durch seine
forschung chronische faulheit ist
gewöhnen sich ohnehin im augenblick
relativ viele menschen daran
ein leben ohne arbeit zu führen das ist
in der krise richtig nur ich habe diese
woche in einem hotel übernachtet wo
praktisch überhaupt kein personal mehr
vorhanden war
ob das mache ich mir keine sekunde
vorstellen in das steigenberger suite
ohne service katastrophe klar im august
über 600.000 arbeitslose mehr als
letztes jahr viele menschen in
kurzarbeit wissen nicht ob ihre firma
corona überlebt aber das eigentliche
problem ist dass wir alle immer fauler
werden friedrich merz sagt schluss damit
du hast angst dass du dich an ein leben
ohne arbeit gewünscht
dann kommen schöne sauerland und arbeite
für friedrich merz hilf ihm sein
flugzeug aufzutanken
sein mofa zu frisieren oder fahren zur
nächsten aufsichtsratssitzung
kurz gesagt mach halt irgendwas zurück
an die arbeit ihre faulen schweine eine
aktion von friedrich merz
sehr schöne aktion kommen wir aber doch
nichts gegen ddr märz aber kommen wir
doch noch mal zu den echten corona
nebenwirkungen der bildungsstandort
deutschland blamiert sich weiter bis auf
die knochen
allein in nordrhein-westfalen und bayern
sind schon wieder über 15.000 schüler in
corona quarantäne form kanzler müssten
eigentlich jeden tag jugendliche
demonstrieren für vernünftigen digital
unterricht ja natürlich denn ein halbes
jahr nachdem homeschooling fiasko haben
wir immer noch kein konzept dafür warum
nicht so dürfen vielleicht doch alle
schulen irgendwann wieder dichtmachen
daher müssen wir die digitalisierung der
schulen mit hochdruck weiter
vorantreiben
mit hochdruck ja dann kauft er doch ein
klarer liebe frau merkel im namen
wirklich alle eltern und schüler hören
sie bitte auf uns mit digital phrasen
abzuspeisen lassen sie den hehren worten
endlich taten folgen
entschuldigung hochdruck ja hochdruck
wäre schön
am montag gab es im kanzleramt merkels
treffen mit den kultusministern hier
anschließend verkündet wurde folgendes
ergebnis
zitat wir haben handlungsstränge
identifiziert herzlichen glückwunsch
ein gipfel bei dem originalen nichts
neues raus kommt nichts
auch die 500 millionen euro für lehrer
laptops hatten sie in wirklichkeit schon
vor wochen beschlossen und endgeräte
lösen ja nicht das eigentliche problem
an unseren schulen die endgeräte die
versprochen wurden für die ich für die
schüler sind vielleicht im jammer
februar da ich habe in der ganzen schule
keine wlan kein wlan kannst den ipad nur
unter den tisch legen wenn der wackelt
andere schulen haben natürlich mehr
glück die stehen direkt neben mcdonalds
da gibt es gratis wlan frage warum kommt
der gipfel im kanzleramt erst jetzt kam
das neue schuljahr irgendwie
überraschend ebenfalls erst diese woche
gab es einen sogenannten lüftungs gipfel
so heißt er wirklich oder ist er
wirklich wo anscheinend erstmals
lüftungskonzept erörtert wurden hier
exklusive bilder
lüften ist tatsächlich total wichtig
wirklich schade bloß dass sich die
fenster in vielen deutschen schulen gar
nicht öffnen lassen
und wo sie sich öffnen lassen entstehen
ganz andere probleme von clinton
es sind sechs grad an diesem morgen
einige lehrkräfte haben sie schon krank
gemeldet wegen des permanenten durchzugs
natürlich haben sie das natürlich er
muss man abwägen corona oder steifer
nacken schwierig deutschlands corona
management ist ja in vielen bereichen
gar nicht mal so schlecht war was die
schulen angeht ist das wort versagen
noch untertrieben freunde nur sechs
prozent unserer schüler hatten täglich
gemeinsam online unterricht 6 prozent
weil wir das thema seit jahren verpennen
seit jahren das geht auch anders
also woanders geht es anders laut der
studie verfügten nur 26 prozent der
deutschen schulen über einen wlan oder
breitbandzugang in dänemark 100 prozent
denen geht's wohl zu gut denn wie uns
kann es auch besser gehen digital seit
anderthalb jahren stehen unseren schulen
nämlich danke digital packt 5 milliarden
vom bund zur verfügung abgerufen bis
heute 16 millionen also ungefähr 0,3
prozent nach anderthalb jahren warum
unter anderem wegen bürokratie ihre sind
ja wir unsere berühmten deutschen
leitkultur
um geld zu beantragen müssen schulen
unter anderem einen aufwendigen medien
entwicklungsplan erstellen liebe schüler
kleiner tipp in der zeit in der rektor
den medien entwicklungsplan schreibt
könnt ihr mit euren eltern nach dänemark
umziehen dort abitur machen studieren
arzt werden heiraten kinder kriegen nur
jüngere frau heiraten mit der auch
kinder kriegen und dann mit mitte 50
eure alte schule besuchen wo der rektor
immer noch am medien entwicklungsplan
sitzt traurig ja liebe partypeople und
feierbiester euren spaß baden am ende
nicht zuletzt die schüler aus ich sag
nur münchen seit gestern masken pflicht
und alkoholverbot auf bestimmten
öffentlichen plätzen aber gleichzeitig
wirtshaus wissen
machen sie das die bayern und vor allem
warum wir scheint mal live ins brauhaus
zum hustenden landmann samaria stockhaus
ist der eigentümer
herr stocker aus wirtshaus wiesen muss
das sein
die wiesn dieses lebensgefühl die
geselligkeit der alkohol was reimt sich
auf lederhose leberzirrhose
denn es ist sehr gefährlich ist ja nur
die wilde saufereien draußen auf den
plätzen wo ich gar nichts dran verdienen
was wir hier machen sie ist ja gerade
kontrolliert es laufen
das heißt dass das heißt ich
kontrolliere das keiner unter vier maß
heim geht sparsam welche spaß
wir achten auf abstände hygieneregeln
zugabe die musik der blaskapelle geht ja
nicht wegen euro soll aus der tube
macht nix spielen wir eben luft über und
luft posaune
hier sind die koro radfahrer
maskenträger wunderbar dieburger
kontrolliert das feiern und trotzdem das
volle wiesen gefühl gut manches kann ich
nicht simulieren was die echte wiesn
bietet die fahrgeschäfte beispielsweise
wenn dein schweinsbraten denkt ich hab
keine lust mehr auf karussell steig aus
und zugegeben auch die romantik kommt
dieses jahr vielleicht etwas zu kurz ich
sag mal was sonst noch hinterm zelt
geschieht das geht in dort auch nur sehr
begrenzt wie schade also wirklich und
ohne jede ironie größtes verständnis für
die gastronomen die um ihre existenz
kämpfen aber hat die erste welle in
bayern nicht auch mit diesen starkbier
festen angefangen entschuldigung das
kann man ja überhaupt nicht vergleichen
starkbier hat er einen viel höheren
stammwürze anteil als ein normales
schank wir die meiste ist auch
dickflüssiger also völlig andere
situation
warum wird bayern eigentlich so gefeiert
für sein pandemie management im sommer
hat er noch zehntausende testergebnisse
verdoppelt also jetzt spricht aber doch
der neid aus in der welt nur der
freistaat schafft es eben knallhartes
corolla management mit lebensfreude zu
verbinden ich sag nur der fc bayern die
bayern bosse können sich ohne maske
gegenseitig auf dem schoß sitzen und
gleichzeitig vorbild für kinder seien
für die nächste wesen arbeite ich
übrigens schon an einem corona
schutzanzug alois kommst mir eine das
ist der hammer
da fühle ich oben über einen schlauch 3
liter helles ein und der alois säuft
sich dann von unten nach oben wieder
raus genial bavaria germany's innovation
nation mich überzeugt aber stocker aus
alter der club hatte er wieder alles
wahnsinn inhaltlich stark satire comedy
gruppe
ich habe es noch drauf also ich würde
den kanal direkt abonnieren und auf
gefällt mir drücken wenn ich das nicht
schon getan hätte
stark jungen
[Musik]